avec Ségolène Royal et Benoît Hamon mais
sans Bernard Cazeneuve vous encore
Carole delgas chef de fil des antinus
c'est un PS en ordre dispersé qui a
donné le coup d'envoi aujourd'hui de sa
traditionnelle universitaire d'été à
Blois en revanche le parti de l'olivier
fort peut compter sur les députés
insoumis et vert et ce malgré les
divergences de stratégies pour les
élections européennes de 2024 clémenced
le Parti socialiste sera populaire ou ne
sera pas ce sont les mots de Philippe
Brun députés de leur au discours
d'ouverture du campus aujourd'hui à
Blois une rentrée avec pour thématique
la reconquête de la France Pérou urbaine
alors même que l'avenir du PS avait ou
sans la nupesse et dans tous les esprits
mais moi je suis pour on va dire une
liste unique aux européennes car le PS a
une indépendance aussi on n'a pas du
tout les mêmes valeurs entre les
socialistes et la France insoumise qui
est elle anti-européen et nous
pro-européens associaliste un communiste
un insoumis en écologiste vont pas avoir
la même vision de l'Europe c'est vrai
mais on va avoir quelque chose à
construire ensemble pourquoi pour le
bien commun contre le réchauffement
climatique et pour une autre société
les élus locaux le maintiennent l'union
de la gauche fonctionne alors échelle
notamment ici à Blois une entente qui
est même jugée nécessaire par le maire
qu'aujourd'hui la stratégie est ce qu'il
faut qui ressortent de ce campus de
Blois 2023 c'est véritablement un
travail de recherche d'unités du parti
nous avons une lourde responsabilité et
le Parti socialiste doit sortir demain
préparer pour affronter les échéances à
venir à l'approche des élections
européennes et sénatoriales le discours
se veut optimiste d'autant plus qu'à
l'automne prochain les projets de loi
finance et immigrations seront examinées